on le sait tf1 est actuellement au
tournage d'une nouvelle saison all star
de son jeu d'aventuré koh lanta
à l'occasion des 20 ans du programme la
chaîne a décidé de sélectionner les
candidats les plus populaires de
l'émission pour créer un cocktail
explosif car à la fin il n'en restera
qu'un mais ces candidats on retrouve par
exemple teheiura laurent claude ouvre et
10 chez les hommes et jade clémence
coumba ou candice du côté des femmes
au total vingt candidats sélectionnés à
travers les différentes saisons de koh
lanta mais voilà certains d'entre eux
ont été appelés pour participer à
l'émission et n'ont finalement pas été
retenu c'est le cas par exemple de
romuald lafitte vainqueur du retour des
héros en 2009 à qui la production a
promis une place dans l'émission avant
de finalement le mettre sur le banc des
remplaçants
c'est un combat difficile des
annulations de dernière minute et de
faux espoirs qui ont agacé plusieurs
candidats du jeu c'est le cas aussi de
mohamed candidat emblématique de la
saison 5 du programme qui indique est
très déçu d'avoir été mis de côté
de leur côté les fans sont eux aussi
très énervé par ces oublis alors
comprenez vous la colère des candidats
refoulé du casting de koh lanta all star
ce soir les anciens candidats momo et
sakon sont avec nous pour exprimer leur
colère
et ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais on est
pas on n'est pas content là on est con
et colère aller de temps vous n'êtes pas
content du tout prix alors ces bâtards
[Rires]
arbeit ont pas pris magique rien à
rajouter pas tout dit non et c'est
horrible ce à quoi non plus jacob moi
j'ai fait trois sur trois rôles star en
fait j'ai atteint le stade final de
casting c'est à dire au moment où la
faire le vaccin préparé ton sac genre
quelques jours avant le départ
ah ouais mais bon c'est trois faits
comme les sexes de castaldi toi et toi
pareil mois par les toits direct il
tombe à 0 1
j'ai même pas eu de nouvelles moi toi
trop dangereux tournoi un peu dangereux
je suis sur leur but qu'a voulu fêter
l'aïd sur tf1 ils sont tous un peu
risqué n'a été déçu moi je suis déçu
surtout victorieux varta place moi moi
franchement j'aurais été patron du
casting sur et me direz quoi tentation à
moi alors je dis même de la place jean
bart et je veux dire à la place de qui
alors déjà et atterrira météo mais
maintenant ils ne mettent pas en effet
plus d'antennes qu'arthur c'est un truc
de ouf vous faire et les jo qui va les
regarder
allawi a commencé en polynésie c'est un
deal avec la production à lui l'année
prix parce que c'est leur égérie les
premiers bons s'est arraché les autres
il affine bizet minimiser alors luis
filipe 50 ans qui a participé à deux
koh-lanta et quand on pense à lui on se
rappelle de son fair play pour appeler
ou pas un jeu lors de l'épreuve
d'orientation
oui il avait donné le poignard qu'il
venait de trouver c'est une crème le
regard de ces univers alors regardez ça
va beaucoup comme un ça va c'est quand
c'est moi
l'histoire est encore une chance je te
veux dans ma lancée pour trouver c'était
mon trip pour gwen rien tu vois
parfaitement taillé spéculatifs unis
c'est lui tutu donc oui tu vas y tu es
weir est ce que tu voulais ce que vous
ne validez tous les deux moi je vois les
toi tu valides pas philippe m'explique
que je voulais faire comme antoine
mangin contre lui ça fait quoi cinq
colons thackeray fait 36 collier
d'immunité elle habite à côté là alors
vers une bijouterie avec elle a produit
le faire gagner français les gens
l'adorent
s'il a la dent il adore aussi
sur un choix boys alors attendez
attendez j'arrive ya également laurent
messac oui bon matin bombe atomique
on va les pleurants mestrez pense que
laurent et va le faire à cyril parce que
il a un hommage en danse un moment qu'il
a perdue a pendant longtemps j'ai ador
cedeao bisous alors savamment allemagne
et touché et c'est un gars vraiment
jeu-là d'or lorsqu'il est parti dans cet
état d'esprit à mais laurent il est un
très très grand aventurier en plus dans
l'extrait que vous allez voir lors on
est tellement contents de trouver son
poignard lors de l'épreuve d'orientation
qu'il hurle à pleins poumons se rappelle
de sa soeur higuain ou tu nous mets sur
l'hymne frère resté huit ans à chercher
le podium
le poignard dans laquelle guy degrenne
moutons c'est la trouver
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lion
le lion est toujours dans l'aventuré
mais tes peurs de koh lanta all stars il
est quand même très très fort et chérien
l'oncle alors en extrait vraiment un
aventurier exceptionnelle avec don pour
l'instant pourrait les trois premiers
candidats pour l'instant vous validez
pour tous a dit mam et donc toi tu
valides les jeux d'argent une petite
réserve sur ce film on file à petit fils
pourquoi c'est pas un c'est pas un
candidat très très marquants de
commenter alors il me rappelait tu vois
mais si voilà c'est mais il est il était
alors oui moi je comprends leur colère
ce qui est une forme d'injustice et
toujours les mêmes qu'on met dans koh
lanta j'ai sorti les recorman de
participation il ya claude cinq
participations
freddy cinq participations nouveaux
seins candidats marquants de koh lanta
il l'a fait que deux fois
donc je pense qu'à des candidats qui ont
la carte et d'autres qui n'ont pas la
carte et j'ajoute à ça qu'ils ont black
listé tous les candidats qui ont fait de
la télé réalité parents comme moi super
dandy dac oi faille d'abord parce
qu'elle a fait intéressant et ça c'est
sa cousine wifi ya des candidats qui
sont là car c'est un des producteurs
moi je moi moi je vous adore belge
puisque leur choix pour le coup il est
justifié
après qu'ils se soient pas contents
c'est tout à fait normal mais le pays
d'où ils ont pris les candidats qui à
mon avis fonctionner le plus auprès des
gens qui regardent le programme et c'est
tout c'est un rapport à eux on a peu en
déroule le casting grèvera ya sam
ouais mais ça m'a dit oui mais omar al
hiti
sa magnitude chez toi qui es pas gagné
mais ils devaient gagner plus mature
pour son âge
voilà regard des femmes qui étaient
avant il était donc la vérité qui compte
c'est lucas pourront gagner les gens ils
étaient très très fort il sait vraiment
tout faire et fait partie du casting
[Musique]
maintenant j'ai un peu levé le pied
je veux qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités et qu'ils sont chrétiens
je vais pas tout faire non plus tout
cela donc
c'est une nouvelle fois la flèche noire
pour la quatrième fois sam
vous êtes le meilleur mais en fait pour
être honnête avec roudani l'art est
content je m'en fous moi ce que je
voulais c'est gagné et ça c'est la plus
grande récompense femmes
ace combat l'idsa juridiques ont empêché
une carte suis content mais pas banal et
vous comprenez pas la colère coco non
mais je comprends qu'ils soient frustrés
évidemment il faut évidemment mais tout
à l'heure tu disais oui mais je
comprends pas que ces actes tels
producteurs tu sais que les actrices
comme oui et quand on fait un casting
c'est comme la théorie des dominos c'est
à dire qu'il faut m et comme quand on
fait une table ici-bas existe moi je
connais très bien un moment où il y en a
pas alors moi je voulais moi j'ai une
théorie moi c'est la théorie des dominos
mais qui tombe
oui mais quand on fait voilà comme quand
on fait une table ici il faut les
personnages qui vont les uns avec les
autres qui font pas doublon il faut une
femme il faut âgées faut pas gêner celle
alors il annoncé après vous auriez pris
vous auriez pris sa koné mohamed ou pas
ben non très honnêtement non non non non
je vous aime beaucoup ce qu'ils
connaissent koh lanta ils savent que
savent s'ils connaissaient palmarès ils
connaissent tous à base là vous voilà
maintenant on va passer justement on
sent qu'un soin d accueil sont seulement
s'il ya max liberia maxime berton alors
maxime je glisse jacky berton puisqu'à
je ne connais pas si vous avez des jeux
med passagers qui n'ont mais maxime
berton
donc c'est pas qui c'est j'ai gardé ça
va pas le casting a parlé d'eux parce
qu'il fait mais pourquoi parce que c'est
très bon ouvrage est très lisse comme
casting 2 pourquoi ils sont pas là la
seule raison c'est parce que c'est des
grandes gueules et qu'ils ont de la
personnalité et ce à quoi ce qu'ils ont
eu peur d'eux mais bien sûr sacconi la
effet un individu a calé pour ceux qui
pensaient boom il a été viré
ça ça va pas alors c'est un casting où
il se passera rien voilà également
freddy alors freddy les
[Applaudissements]
très doux gauche et candidat bricolo qui
a participé à quatre reprises du jeu
d'ea sont un expert pour construire les
cabanes il est très fort lui aussi sa
soeur dans le jeu et les intentions de
jauzion l'appel dont l'ascension freddy
en quelques jours a rapporté
réorganisation complète du pont
l'ingénieur en chef c'est un architecte
autour de l'iddac je suppose qu'il est
exactement mais c'est tout faire de bach
à cadéac il ya une hiérarchie texte ça
fait plaisir ça ça montre qui a baptisé
qui remarque mes efforts qui remarque
que je m'investis énormément dans ce que
j'entreprends je ferai jamais il nous
fait une nouvelle des scrupules propose
sa façade à la partie de l'émission
merci c'est parti nourdine pas dire moi
ça exprès débouchés on est tous d'accord
on va les marais dit alors oui oui alors
jugé utile verdez basse et oui baptisé
belle cabane mais c'est pas quelqu'un
qui est investi
mais ces petits brins berry n'a pas un
énorme intérêt mais oui parce que c'est
des grandes gueules et vous [ __ ] à
quelque chose après ce sera une âme
moi je partirai bouger je dors de suivi
oui moi je pense je peux comprendre la
frustration en revanche la colère je
comprends pas parce qu'il y aura deux
éminents sauf que pour une prochaine
émission all stars vous serez contacté
juste rien n'est perdu rien les experts
n'avaient pas parce qu il y disait la
saison on a fait en 2005 avec mohamed on
a eu des pics d'audience à 6
en fait on présentait toute la
population et je suis le seul the ninja
café campus non mais en plus serré que
si les grandes gueules
alors il y en a un autre sénat mahdia à
bah oui c'est la famille étant à imputer
à sabrer le candidat de la saison 12
lors de cette édition il avait trouvé un
collier d'immunité l'a utilisé pour se
sauver lors d'un conseil regardez était
très sympathique très sympathique
ce quelqu'un à un collier d'immunité et
souhaite le jouer ce soir
va falloir que je fasse un peu de
refroidissement à tout ça
o na dia comme vous avez sorti ce
collier d'immunité
si à l'intérieur de saturne il ya des
votes contre vous il ne seront pas
comptabilisé la manière na mahdia nama
dia mamadou nama dia à mahdia
javier javier prenez votre sac aller
récupérer votre plan d'eau et venez me
rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
c'est un bon moment le meilleur conseil
est ouest et trèbes meilleurs conseils
alors il ya hugo l'artiche hugo n'est
pas sûr d'accord j'ai pas d'image je
vous dis la vérité
il ya patrick merle à vous rappeler ou
pas ils essaient de collier d'immunité
mais selon lui le moment alors patrick
vous rappelez plus patrick nom du nord
regarde et patrick ont gardé pour moi ça
va vraiment changer aventure tout âge et
le collier ou la bâtisse la beia bas
patrick faites attention il cache son
maillot de bain derrière des balles
incroyables
patrick a trouvé le second collier
d'immunité ouais je conviens patrick
ollier jaune c'est que ce collier vous
qualifie d'office pour la finale
l'ag sûr merci qui a le deuxième collier
d'immunité mois de nu non si je
comprends bien patrick ça fait un moment
vous êtes serein dans cette aventure koh
lanta
lectra est frais énormes chantiers pour
lui on valide ou pas du tout ce qui est
drôle c'est qu'ils ont la majorité qui
ont dit non ils connaissent pas les
candidats mais bien sûr vous allez me
mohamed vous allez me détester je suis
désolé en avoir un je vous aime quand
même mais moi je me souviens que de
l'épisode de la chèvre mais foba c'est
pour ça que je suis désolé donc ses
futurs cadets ce koh lanta ne se
souviennent pas que de la chaîne mais
moi [ __ ] je je je me souviens j'ai
regardé toutes les saisons effectivement
les candidats là certains je ne me
souviens plus mais c'est vrai que cet
épisode qui m'a marqué - les
performances excuse non non non je suis
changé d'avis moi je suis pas loin de
changer effectivement quand je les vois
là y'en a un joker il avait tout à fait
sa place parce qu on se souvient de tout
litige
on se souvient de lâcher un très bonne
aventure hier j'ai juste une petite
parenthèse comme ça sans prétention avec
claude sur une saison on a le même
palmarès sont les immunités
oui je sais ça c'est ben justement
claudie liés aux lilas qui a vraiment
marqué les téléspectateurs et claude
déjà trois participations
rappelez vous quand il aider les autres
candidats à l'orientation claude
obligatoire il fallait le mettre ko
nicher mais oui c'est de ouais on et de
la sueur roche la roche c'est la base
c'est sur la flanc de falaise là
la plage de donnie walsh posant
d'ailleurs pour elles c'est toute cette
zone là bas là bas faire le caillou
d'helaba n'est pas prêt de l'eau à
l'intérieur de forêt jeu fracassé une
fatigue aussi n'a pas chômé nos gros
shoots à donne le connais comme ça elle
est après les murets de pierre frey tu
vas par là c'est pas dans la bonne zone
moussa vous n'êtes pas dans la bonne
zone encore vous comprenez pas et on a
aussi l'épisode rappeler où et quand il
perd au poteau oui oui arni ça ça ça m'a
tuer ça chez fusion impôt tout net
claude nawel duel final de cette saison
de koh lanta l'île des héros l'épreuve
va encore se compliquer rendez vous
compte
vous allez vous retrouver en équilibre
sur un carré
[Musique]
la victoire pour nawal 2h30
2h30 moi-même au sol pendant qu'un je
trouve moi c'est qu'il marque ans comme
moi j'adorais c'était grégoire vous en
rappellerez voir s'arrêter par grégoire
n'est pas dans les reee attendait dans
la chanson barça
alors oui mal casting aussi femme de koh
lanta est serré il est fort et alexandra
a frappé par alexandre avait eu des
débuts difficiles
elle était présentée comme la
wonderwoman du programme mais ses débuts
ont été laborieux regarder son voisin
koh lanta ça a toujours été le rêve de
ma vie et je ferais peut devenir pour
mes films super héroïne com - de
roumanie dollar actif sur l'île je vais
activer le mode super héroïne ce sera ma
détermination qui me fera à gagner koh
lanta
j'aime bien mon petit confort ami jerry
de notre vie à dire ouais alors elle
normal qu'elle soit dans le casting
sinon j'adore coumba alex très fort
méconnu de saison est très fort elle a
participé à trois koh-lanta je vous
propose de revoir l'une des faux c'est
presque parti au clash avec l'un des
autres aventuriers on est d'accord sur
tout mais attend un petit nous lâchait
vont leurs relations dans tous les cas
c'est il ya là qu'il va la manger la
mondiale actuelle pas la manger la
manche quand il force personnellement
dans l'es7 s'ils sont d'accord une
personne n'est pas d'accord donc c'est
la majorité qui l'emportent c'est ça
dans la vie en collectivité
il est gentil lui le climat mundi avec
vous dire et voilà on lui on lui fait de
gros bisous moon
et alors pour l'instant le casting je
suis désolé a bien séché cohérent sting
pour moi il est incroyable moi j'ai
envie de quand même de savoir qui va
gagner parce qu'entre claude entre
laurent je suis désolé gilles verdez je
pouvais pas dire que le casting et
réseaux vous avez cinq all star et 5 qui
ne sont pas star donc c'est pour ça que
ça va pas ça manque de personnalité ces
termes mais fausse aux poudres et ben si
j'avais que des bons chroniqueurs
[Rires]
j'ai tout ce dont les bombes
ressortirait pas annuler un bout une
grosse personnalité n'est pas du tout
lisse donc ça va complètement à part ça
le q10 gilles
alors oui et on a l'impression qu'ils
vont faire le buzz parce que clémentine
elle n'a pas non plus brillé c'est pas
pour moi la candidate qui s'est révélé
en tant que aventurière mais par contre
elle était détesté sur les réseaux
sociaux
donc la prendre c'est ce que vous
vouliez dire au début de saison je crois
pas du tout il est chéri il ya alix ma
peine a dit quinn alexis noblat alors
vous vous rappelez pas regarder ces
lapins des items de la dernière saison à
la fin de téléralité away d'après cet
égard parce que tu ne connais pas on est
on a fait attention et dans l'extrait
que vous allez voir la jeune femme bon
j'ai un cafard oui très bon pied et on
peut le mettre combien on va le jouer
juste le décrire entamant et c'est mon
confort
tremper dans l'eau de mer on va le
remettre aux grilles on va le sa légère
avance faire une chips quand il mange
mon 24 jamais dans ma vie j'aurais fait
ça attention je préfère que m ashok
d'autres canons mais ça goûte barbichu
le goût d'une équipe c'est un goût de
grillé c'est bon les deux spécialistes
khalid n'y a rien de transcendant elano
des candidates qui ont vraiment marqué
l'aventuré c'est trop tôt trop tôt
surtout c'est bien d'être dans la lah
lagarde c'est ça le il ya tellement de
candidats et on a tout ce à quoi vous
n'avez pas été presque penser que vous
fait peur aux eaux aux gens du casting
de koh lanta dit la vérité moi j'ai eu
moi j'ai eu le producteur est devenu au
téléphone ouais m'ont appelé ils m'ont
appelé m'ont dit bon écoute tu faisais
pas partie des 40 meilleurs
ah ouais c'est ça 48 sont bien foutus de
vaux d'yonne voilà c'est voici pour vous
ils sont foutus de notre gueule ou par
non c'est une peine mais après denis m'a
fait comprendre en gros on écoute la
route à la longue ça peut ça peut
aboutir sur d'autres choses c'est parce
que c'est pour quoi faire
je voulais le fait et les ventes on va
pas vous mentir vous fermez vos gueules
faut être malin ils savent très bien il
se dit mohamed sahnoun à ce soir il faut
le calmer parce que sinon il va arriver
il va tout défoncer jeudi en kiosque ils
vous ont dit oui on va faire pour faire
rôle star t'inquiète pas mais chez toi
se sont bien foutus de bataille c'est le
ramadan non mais c'est vrai moi je vous
dis moi je pense vous ferez jamais le
all-star crois oui pourquoi parce que je
pense qu'il se foute de vous je crois
oui bien sûr non la vérité ce que vous
n'y croyez pas
ap depuis longtemps si les efforts gaza
a provoqué tous leurs voeux ils ont fait
pareil taper encore y aura plus
d'aventuriers les données ont fait le
pari mais moi j'espère vraiment que
c'est quoi moi mon môme je rêve que tu
sois c'est comme je suis fan de toi et
je sais ce que tu fais en plus en
novembre et je sais comme tu fais là
c'est un garçon exceptionnel moment où
je suis à l'aise et c'est un mec qui
fait du bien et eux ils jouent
aujourd'hui je comprends pas pourquoi tu
n'y es pas et ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'on a voulu montrer cette image tu
sais un tout nouveau petit quartier tout
ça mais c'est une belgique par tout ce
qui fait ses humanités et giuly et momo
je te lis moi je te dis qu'il se fout de
ta gueule oui mais la vérité c'est qu'au
fil des saisons dans koh lanta les
castings sont de plus en plus lisse de
plus en plus et du rail à dubaï attaque
l'otan fait dans les relances et l'âme
dans les dernières saisons c'est de plus
en plus lisse de plus en plus phil woods
parce que c'est la nouvelle image que
que vous rendre là de tf1 et que des
candidats comme à mettre ces îles sont
beaucoup trop fort en gueule et ils ont
un trop fort caractère et ça peut
déraper en tournage donc ça les dérange
alors c'est ça qu'on aime encore y en a
une aussi qu'ils étaient sectionnées
c'est cindy cindy poumeyrol alors elle
elle est connue pour avoir caché un
collier dans sa culotte organes mais
c'est vrai
les gros arbres comme ça il sait très
bien qu'elle en milieu sur le coupé
j'ai trouvé
j'avais juste en débardeur m tee shirt
donc je les cache une arnaque hulotte
c'était assez douloureux sympathie la
téléréalité effectivement vous avez
raison et il n'est pas près d 1,8
chaconne est ce que tu es d'accord avec
moi moi je pense que oui et que pour moi
m malheureusement c'est cuit c'est
pourquoi si c'était pas dans le pass
comme l'a dit on voit m c'est un
personnage
moi je fais le casting de mon état dans
les biens est grand il ya eu qui savent
l'acquis qui sauve la production pour
qu'elles n'ont pas pris mohamed ils
avaient tous mois pas moins pas dans les
vingt ans mais dans les eaux star
précédent j'avais ma vie j'étais loin
médecine mohamed il est pas dans les
vingt ans pour moi elle avait tout à
fait sa place
bah oui tout le monde se souvient de lui
il dit
il devait être dans les vingt ans s'il
n'est pas dans les vingt ans il sera
jamais et ce qui est tendu exactement
voit la route a été longue à les uns que
peut-être il y avait de l'espoir pour un
autre koh lanta all star d'accord tu
veillette et schoeller met la pression
sur la chance j'ai dit ça y est on
obligé de s'y mettre
bah oui c'est sûr c'est sûr et certain
moi je garde à vue alors c'est un
vainqueur de la saison 5 du combat des
abats et membre du jury final retour des
ombres est normal qu'elle y soit c'est
la seule à avoir gagné deux fois donc
exactement yaël et ma mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop facile j'espère que les
souris pour tous les instants gagnants
mais c'est sûr elle va vous oui oui
alors oui franchement moi je trouve
qu'il ya plus de personnalité chez les
femmes
oui les hommes c'est plus lisse et plus
des spécialistes des épreuves et chez
les femmes il ya une plus grande
richesse elles sont un peu moins connus
mais je trouve que voilà lahm sera chez
les femmes il veut dire qu'il ya plus de
laniscourt